This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart.
And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts.
The True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube.
Start listening to Scam Goddess on the Icom. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants.
And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to decoding women's health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal,
Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life until the messages started. is not going to make it out of this alive. Every piece of evidence pointed to the wrong guy. He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our
psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so lovely to have you here back around these parts today as we discussed the psychology of our 20s, specifically the five reasons you are not as behind as you think. This has to be one of the most prominent, I would say the most widely felt experiences of our 20s and probably our 30s as well. This sense that life is this race, there is a big checklist of things that we need to do and we need to accomplish, and we are all simultaneously failing. There is somebody ahead of us who is doing more, who is accomplished more, and if we don't catch up to them and we don't catch up to them soon, well, some big bad thing is going to transpire, and we're never going to be happy,
we're never going to be successful, we're going to be miserable for the rest of our lives. I have felt this countless times in my 20s so far. I genuinely feel like it's my little emotional shadow at this stage. And I'm fairly certain a lot of you have felt it as well, which is kind of funny. And it's ironic because if we are all feeling behind, who exactly is ahead? Like, it's a tricky feeling. What we have to realize is that this feeling is actually one of our brain's favorite ways to catastrophize. And yet a lot of what it tells us is highly, highly inaccurate.
it. And it's based on a series of cognitive fallacies that we can actually counteract and really dig into and disprove. So today I actually want to break down these fallacies. I want to break them down one by one so that you can kind of view your situation and the sensation of feeling behind a bit more realistically and hopefully realize like how far ahead you are, how much progress you've made, why you are exactly where you need to be, and how to release this anxiety before it causes you to make irrational decisions or to not like yourself because that's one of the worst things you can do when you are up against this feeling. So without further ado, let's get into the five reasons you are not as behind as you think based on the psychology. So the first reason
you're not as behind as you imagine yourself to be actually has, I think, very little to do with what you have or haven't accomplished or what you have or haven't done. And it has everything to do with who and how you compare yourself to others. One of the main reasons I think you may feel behind is that when you compare yourself to other people of, let's say, around the same age, who are pursuing the same goals that you want to pursue, oftentimes you are comparing yourself to the very best or the most visible version of this. And that is what's making you miserable. This is a cognitive bias. It actually has a name. It's called the survivorship bias. And it occurs when we mistake the subgroup of the most successful as the entire group. And because we aren't what we would deem one of the most
successful, we therefore, you know, we're not part of the majority. We are not part of this group of everybody else who's doing great. We are in this small special group of failures. These kind of groups don't exist. Social media especially is one of the main corporate here and making us feel this way, when that's not how life works. You know, it's, it's normal to experience comparison. It's normal to really pay attention to success stories. But I think nowadays, because people, you know, choose to share so much more, social media gives the impression of visibility over others' lives that gives the impression of a full story when actually, even that full story is still curated. Like, even when we are seeing other people,
people's failures, they are still the failures that they have chosen to show us. There is still some kind of facade that makes things always look polished. I'm somebody with a social media presence. I would say it's a modest one, but still. And I've even found that like if I share vulnerable stuff and if I share my failures, I kind of only shared like sexy failures. Like I'm not sharing the full extent of things. And I'm definitely not sharing the regularity at which they're happening. Like, I'm not going to talk about business failures or financial failures or tax failures or family failures, mainly for privacy, if I'm, if I'm being honest. But I do still think, like, I know I'm doing it. I know everybody else is doing it. And I know that it's contributing
to this collective image that we know our own pain and we know our own failures very well. We think we know others because we think we have this visibility over their lives. We really don't. We really don't. And I think we We all know, like, yeah, social media is fake. But even the stuff that doesn't look fake is still sometimes fake. That's what I'm trying to say, you know. And then on top of that, like, the content that doesn't talk about that stuff still continues to rise to the surface.
Content that is lavish, successful, that shows a very particular kind of lifestyle is compelling and is something that we are going to pay more attention to, especially since we don't see it very often in the real world. Science backs this up. It backs up the fact that social media is literally optimized to show us aspirational content. I would really recommend this book. It's called The Chaos Machine by Mark Fisher. And he dives into this more. And what he basically says is how Instagram and TikTok is a machine that was programmed by people who really understood the brain. and it works because it selects the most provocative and emotional content and feeds that to us. That means the bad stuff, obviously, but it also just means a selection of outliers.
It shows us outliers, which is why we only ever see the most lavish, perfect version of life or the most awful tragedies or the most shocking stuff. And we would, if we're, you know, it's natural, we're seeing that all the time, begin to think that that's all the world is. And the reason that we're getting shown this stuff is because it triggers an emotional reaction. It triggers envy. It triggers comparison. It triggers confusion, jealousy, all of which are complex emotions that keep us going back to the source.
Keep us going back to social media. A study from 2022 actually had, I think it was like 300 people in the US look at 20 social media influencer posts. And afterwards, they measured their, effective well-being, effective well-being basically means like the intensity of your positive and negative emotions. And they also measured their level of envy and their level of inspiration towards the influencer. What the study revealed was a negative correlation between looking at social media posts and well-being. They also noticed a positive correlation, I will say, between this same feeling and occasionally feelings of inspiration, but only when the content or the
lifestyle felt reachable. And most of it doesn't. And most of us just gives us the impression that we are absolutely failing at life. We are existing in these online environments, sometimes for six plus hours a day. And these are environments that are designed to intentionally make you feel bad about yourself. I don't think it's the content creator's fault. I think it's what gets pushed and what becomes popular. And so the reason you feel so behind is because you are sitting in this artificial space that's just meant to make you feel really bad about yourself. And I think you would notice that if you got off your phone, even for a couple of days, got off social media even for a couple of days, if you stepped out of this atmosphere environment, like this space, you would feel so much
better. And you would actually just realize and have this deep epiphany of how normal most people's lives are and how well you really are doing. You know, even if you're not where you want to be yet, I truly do believe, like maybe you're just exactly where you need to be. Not everyone can be the most successful version of themselves in their 20s. In fact, I actually, I don't think it's that healthy to be that. I don't think it's healthy to be the best at something and to be everything you've ever wanted to be at 25. So don't discount your progress and your achievements just because somebody is doing more or because you think that you could be doing more. Sometimes it's all, it happens according to plan.
It all is going to be okay. I also believe that we get into this trap of like feeling like we're behind because And this is the second reason we feel behind. We treat envy like it is something to be avoided rather than something that can actually be useful or manageable. Now, that might sound like it contradicts what I just said. You know, I just said like social media makes us feel bad because it elicits feelings of jealousy. And jealousy in itself must be negative and hurtful and wrong. Therefore, we must avoid social media, get away from it so that the jealous feelings go away. I want to explain this a little bit further, though, because that's actually not what I mean. We cannot separate the feeling of envy and the feeling of being behind. That also means that if we treat envy differently and we change our relationship to it, our sense of being behind will also perhaps lessen and also improve. Typically, when we, I would say, I would say this is for the majority of people when we experience an emotion like envy or jealousy or anything like that. Our greatest reaction is just to like get a
far away from it as possible, like really psychologically put as much distance between us and that feeling as we can. We've definitely been socialized that jealousy is bad, it's unpleasant, it's uncomfortable, it's selfish. So when it naturally comes up because it's a human emotion and it will, all that is met with is guilt and shame and self-judgment, and that just makes us feel really crap. Envy has levels and envy has layers to it that is not spoken about enough. There is benign envy and there is malicious envy.
malicious envy creates inferiority means that we may try and tear somebody down, disregard them, undermine them. Malicious envy is not helpful and it's the kind of envy that ruins our self-esteem and it doesn't make us feel good. It doesn't make us a good person either. The nine envy or emulative envy on the other hand is actually motivational and it's aspirational. And so what that means is that it encourages us to actually do more. And I think this is for two reasons. The first reason why benign or emulative envy helps us be better is that if we are jealous of a situation, that provides some of the clearest evidence that that is actually what you want in life.
So the reason that envy, benign envy is helpful, it is like one of the clearest big red flags, big shining lights pointing to something that you secretly want and that you secretly desire. It is a mirror. like envy is a mirror because if you didn't secretly want that, why would you be having such an intense reaction about somebody who has it? Secondly, I think benign envy then shows us what is possible. We wouldn't feel jealous of something if it didn't exist. The proof that this person has it and exists is proof that we can also have it. Here's this person, I'm feeling this conflicting emotion. Perhaps the best direction for that emotion to take is towards curiosity and is about
examining the steps that they took to obtain the thing that I really want for myself. Like, I want that life. I want that relationship. I want that feeling. So rethink envy, rethink the negative sensation that is attached to that feeling. And I think you, like, suddenly have access to such a powerful emotional force that you can harness. I read this. Actually, I don't think I read this. I think a friend told me about this interesting relationship that Michael Jackson and Prince had, and they had this, like, rivalry where they really drove each other to perform better. and Michael Jackson would be like, well, I have to do this because if I don't do it, like Prince is going to do it.
Like, Prince is going to steal my idea. And like it really pushed them both to like be the artist that they became and to have these like legendary legacies because they used envy as a compass and as a form of motivation. So I think that's another reason why you aren't as behind as you think. You're not treating envy in a way that it can help you. think if you were, you would realize that whilst you sit looking at somebody else's life feeling jealous of it, there is so much that maybe you could be doing to gain a life that's not the same, but might feel similar and might make you really happy. The other thing, and the third reason
why I think you feel behind, is because whilst you are comparing yourself to these phenomenal individuals, you might not realize how many people are comparing themselves to you. And you probably don't appreciate that you yourself are an outlier, especially in a global context. I don't, I think there is a lot that you are not giving yourself credit for that you should be. And I want to kind of shine a light on that after the short break. So stay with us. The music you love. Your favorite radio stations. Everywhere you go. The podcasts everyone's talking about. All in one place. And it's free.
I heart radio Whatever you want to hear Listen anytime Anywhere Music, radio Podcasts Unlimited audio It's on the free
IHurt Radio app One app No subscription Always free Grab the free Every way you go Always free Download the free
IHard radio app today Lisa We should tell them about our new show Oh my God Lexi We have a new podcast It's called Don't Lie to Me I'm Lexi We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart.
And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anyone fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business, and I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dating, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree.
Because you told us how accommodating you are. Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
or wherever you get your podcast. I don't really care. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts, the True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on incredible guests like Conan O'Brien, Iowa Debris, Lamorne Morris, and Nicole Byer.
Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And the scams run the gamut. I'm talking about scams from the 1800s all the way up to today. I also warn you and keep you safe against scammers.
Call your grandparents. Tell your parents to stop clicking on links, please. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. If there's a scam, I'm here to protect you. And I'm also here to laugh with you. So if you like fun, if you like comedy and you like learning and protecting yourself from criminals, start listening to scam goddess on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast.
Hi, this is Kylie Breakman, Angel Geratana, Jeremy Colhane, Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcasts where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal. I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading.
So we don't like to use that word anymore. Okay. A panel of New York. Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class? No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry.
I'm seeing a reading of Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore on 14th. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland Bookstore yesterday and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way. You have to come to the last bookstore, though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes.
Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on artists on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle school is a different world than the one we grew up in.
I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spent real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all of the same job. We got into group chats and gaming,
friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging. You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted. And then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers,
sitting down with therapist Keer Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts so you can't do flips. You have on the dress. You have to cross your legs. That's the range of this run. From screen time to identity to the fathers doing the work at home. You have to get off her device.
But the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their lives to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I want to present some statistics for you here about what the average person is doing. and what the average person has achieved in their 20s, just so that we all, as a group, have a healthier perspective on like what is actually normal
because I feel like we don't. So firstly, money. I'm just going to say, disclaimer, I'm going to base this on statistics from the UK because that's where I live now. But imagine, well, I don't think things would be that radically different to other countries that are perhaps similar. So do your own research on this, but I think that you would find it's probably quite similar. So, money. According to a 2026 finder survey, 18 to 24 year olds have an average of £3,000 in savings, whilst the average 25 to 34 year old has 11,000 pounds. You're probably thinking like, wait,
actually, that sounds like a lot. Remember the average is skewed. The average is skewed by people who have a lot of savings or people who have trust funds or who are high earners. In fact, that survey dug a little bit further, and it showed that two and five people of all ages have a thousand pounds or less in savings. A quarter, 25%, have 200 pounds less or less in savings, and 16% of people had no savings at all. That is a serious amount of people without much money. Forget being able to go on luxury holidays. Like, forget fancy clothes. The majority of people probably couldn't cover an emergency payment. And yet we are thinking that we are behind because we can't afford like the writs or a freaking designer handbag, thinking that
that is the norm. Now this isn't meant to be like making people feel bad and be like, look how awful everybody has it. Ha ha ha. Look how good. We have it. No. I just think it is so vital that you understand the norm and the global norm of what
somebody your age is probably doing. Most people in their 20s cannot afford. all these fancy dinners at restaurants and trips and new clothes and just all the luxuries that we think that we need. What's more? Like maybe you can't afford that. It's probably wise not to choose those things as well. Like perhaps you are saving for a bigger purchase. You're trying to pay off debt. You're trying to help your family. Whatever it is, financial insecurity is actually more normal than not just financial security, but financial luxury. So put that in perspective. remember that next time you think, oh my God, I should be having, I should have more in my bank account.
Another big one is, is home ownership. I feel like that is a very pressing thing in our 20s and 30s. The average age for home ownership is 34. Average, again, still skewed. And the number of people in that age is just getting higher and higher and higher because getting on the property ladder is is harder and harder and harder. Like, homeownership, money, the standard of we have in our mind, the standard that is our perception is highly different to the standard of this reality. Let's talk about some other non-material things. What about friends? How many friends do you think people have? You know, if you were basing this off of your own perception or what you see online, you would probably say the average person has 12 friends, 20 friends. The answer is the average person
has one to four close friends. Additionally, actually the average person has like two friends. And we actually might only be able to psychologically manage having five close friends, according to what we know is Dunbar's number. Dunbar's number of theory of friendship was an idea put forward by this British psychologist. His name is Robin Dunbar in the 90s. He is my dream guest on the podcast. So if anybody, I've emailed him so many times. So I was going to say, if anybody has his number, he knows I'm trying to get a hold of him.
He doesn't want to come on the podcast. But what he basically said was that Alburn. and our capacity as social creatures is limited. And we really only have so many relationships that we can juggle. When we see somebody who has 30 close friends, 20 close friends, a group of friends, it's like 10 people and they all seem to get along, I really do think that there is stuff behind the scenes that like you probably don't know about. It's very easy to look at that and think, God, they must be so happy.
God, what a luxury, and not realize how many internal disputes there are, how many people feel excluded at times, how many times those same people still feel very, very lonely. So that's another thing you have to be aware of when you're comparing. What about marriage? So about marriage and relationships and our relative norm versus the, like our perception versus the reality. Again, using the UK data, the average age, a person first marries is 31. In the 90s, oh, sorry, in the 70s it was 23. That is just the start. For every person getting married at 25, there's another person getting married at 35 or 40 or in their 50s and 60s. And for every person getting married at 31, there is somebody getting divorced at 40. You know, in some cases, I actually think this is the
norm now. I think we say it's like 50% of people end up getting divorced. I think it's around 42% now. Like 42% of marriage is end in divorce. There is a statistically significant portion of people who are entering into an engagement or a marriage in their 20s, who look like they have everything together, who further down the line are going to realize they were with the wrong person. And so if you are feeling like that is really far off from you, you've got to remember your own timeline is like absolutely fine. And you might actually be saving yourself from a lot of grief. Dr. Meg Jay, who we know and love, she's the author of The Defining Decade. We had her on the podcast. When she was on the podcast, she said something really interesting.
which is that from her experience, so many 20-somethings get in touch with her and they feel like they're behind. And the thing she always says is that this is your training will decade. And what you think is behind is actually saving you from so much. Our 20s aren't about getting everything done. They're about getting things started. They're about experimenting. If you've done everything you wanted to do in your 20s, everything you ever wanted to do in life in your 20s, what would the rest of your life before. So when you take stock of your life, please remember to include that more global, wider perspective of what the average of things is actually in reality, not just what you expect from yourself, not just thinking that what the average is is what you want
from your life. So to kind of summarize these points, you're not as behind us you think because you are only comparing yourself to allies. You are not as behind as you think because you are misconstruing envy as a negative emotion when it could be a powerful force, and you are not as behind as you think because you're not looking globally. The fourth reason that you are not as behind as you think is also a perspective issue, and it's about something that we know of and we call the social clock. The social clock is a concept that was first introduced by the psychologist Bernice Newgarten all the way back in the 60s. And when Bernice introduced this idea, She basically suggested that a lot of our behavior is unconsciously controlled primarily by a social rather than a biological clock.
And also rather than our own desires, our life is controlled by what we think we should be doing based on what other people expect. We seem to have this idea on our minds of like when we can and when we can't do things or when we should and we shouldn't do things based on our age. And it's fundamentally driven by social norms that indoctrinate this certain appropriate timeline for. life that's actually kind of bullshit. You know, you might hear people saying things like, I'm just too old to be living at home. I'm too old to go back to school. I'm too old to try that. I'm too young to apply for a job like this. Somebody my age should be married by now. Somebody my age should have had their first relationship. If I don't have a kid by this age, I'm never going to. Like that one maybe, but the rest of them, like, where did this idea come from?
How do we learn to be so constrained by age? And additionally, with like the biological clock thing as well, like we have these ideas that like if I don't have a kid by like 35, like I'm basically barren. People like have kids in their 50s these days. Like you are not as constrained by biology as you think. So the first thing to know is that the social clock, not the biological clock, we're back to the social clock, is culturally specific. This was demonstrated in this study published in the journal.
I think it would have been like the social psychology bulletin or social psychology journal. And it looked at the way that cultural beliefs impact the social clock in China and the US. Specifically, what they wanted to figure out was what were the earliest and the latest ages, people in both places, thought it was appropriate to engage in several life events. So things like getting married, having a kid, starting a career. They wanted to show that the social clock that we think is universal is really just cultural. They found that the time windows were much different. So in the US, people felt like they had a much, much larger window to complete certain
milestones like getting married and having a baby and figuring themselves out. And in China, that window was narrower. The rigidity or flexibility of the window, whether it could be moved or not really, influenced the individual's experience of milestone anxiety and the individual's experience of being behind. And what they found was that, even without any... really needing to say anything. When people fell outside these windows where they felt things were appropriate to do or not do, they seem to like fundamentally have this sense of like being
off time. Without anybody really needing to say anything, it was so indoctrinated. What's interesting, though, is that they also found, well, this was a separate study, the majority of people don't abide by the social clock anyway. That's because the social clock is meant to be corrective. It's meant to be punishing and preventative, I guess, rather than helpful. it is actually not the norm. It doesn't necessarily describe what most people are actually doing. It describes what we think culturally a person should be doing. And then it gives us a way to judge ourselves when our lives don't match up with those expectations. The social clock, specifically, I think, what it does is that it convinces us that age is evidence and that we age
and mature and identical ways. Age is evidence of where we should be. Age is actually just information about how long you've been alive for. It's literally just a way of measuring time and measuring maybe health. Age cannot tell you whether you are ready for marriage. The age you are does not determine your emotional maturity. Your age does not give you evidence that the right career is, like just because your 22 doesn't mean your career is right or wrong that you should know. Like age does not predict or tell you like what is right for you. It's just how old you are. The reason you are feeling behind is because you see age as the biggest determinant of what you should or shouldn't be doing yet. And the thing is, is that people
have been disproving the belief that there is a certain timeline that makes people happy for so long. Like some of the happiest people alive got married at 60. They didn't find a job they loved until they were 50. Because our 20s and life in general is defined by this lack of definition, I think we crave anything that can add structure or definition back into our lives. And that blueprint that is provided by the social clock just seems to be the easiest thing to grab onto. If I live my life exactly according to this plan, society has said that I would be happy. I actually don't think it's that helpful and I actually don't think it's the guarantee for happiness that we think it is. I think if you are finding yourself victim to the social clock,
go searching for all the people who haven't abided by this timeline and have yet still found extreme joy and extreme happiness. Because I actually think it's most people. Also, perhaps observe, if you want, the people who have abided by the timeline. Do they seem happier to you? No, I actually don't think they do, because life is so much more nuanced than that. There is no guaranteed formula that if you do things this way, you will be happy. There is a socially prescriptive formula, but, yeah, as I said, I don't know about you.
I encounter slash I see a lot of people in my life, in my family, like just in general, who have done everything by the book, and they don't seem to really be enjoying themselves. So just bear that in mind next time you feel like if I'd done it this way, maybe I'd be more happy. It's the classic grasses greener on the other side dilemma. So my next reason why you may not be as behind as you think is much more psychological. and I think it's a reality. I don't think.
I know it's a reality that a lot of you have experienced and may still be living that you just don't acknowledge or give yourself credit for. You have spent a great deal of your life in survival mode and you are now comparing your progress to someone's end goal, not accounting for all the things that you had to survive
and you had to endure and you had to get through, which they probably do, didn't. And they perhaps did not have to do or survive or endure. You are not giving yourself enough credit for the fact that your start line was different to everyone else's. It's not about making excuses for yourself. I know a lot of people feel very opposed to that. I really just think it's about having grace towards your environment and to the fact that not everybody's environment and start line was the same. We spent a lot of time talking about privilege on this podcast and
talking about things like financial inheritance and money and how people are better set off if their parents were making more and if their parents had a good education and their parents had a good job. Huge advantages. Those are massive advantages. However, I think one of the greatest gifts we can receive that a lot of us don't is a strong emotional inheritance from our parents and from our support system. It is the gift of a loving home, a loving support system that arms us with the belief that like we can really step into the world and we can be resilient and optimistic and like if something goes wrong there is somebody who is going to help us with that problem a lot of people don't have that and when we don't have that and we feel like we're really
on our own we expend a lot more resources just trying to feel secure and trying to feel safe and we expend those resources like we just have to really deal with that before we can turn our mind towards our actual like ambitious true dreams. Like your dream is just to get through this. Other people's dreams who aren't going through this is to like, I want to be a millionaire. I want to do all that. I want to be an artist. You don't, you haven't had the time for that yet. So what actually puts us in survival mode? A lot of things, it can be everything from emotional neglect to experiencing a family breakdown at a young age, chronic trauma, grief at a young age, mental or physical illness at a young age, a natural disaster, having to immigrate, moving around
a lot, anything that disrupts our emotional and physical equilibrium, or like sense of homeostasis, can send an internal message from an early time in our lives that we are not safe. And when we don't feel safe, we don't have the mental resources to focus on flourishing. Flourishing and surviving are opposed. On the outside, if you are somebody who has been in this survival state or in survival mode for a while, yeah, your life might seem really, really normal. You actually might have a really great job and you might have a really great partner and really good friends. You might be a really, really amazing at hiding this part of you and compartmentalizing and functioning very well.
That can make it hard for others to recognize. It can also make it hard for ourselves to recognize that we are still struggling things that are making life harder. But deep down, like, there is a much different picture here. Like, you might think I'm doing really well. But when you are in survival mode, your brain and your body is just hijacked by the sympathetic nervous system. It is hijacked by a continuous hypervigilance and a continuous fight or flight response, which makes you feel constantly on edge.
Your body, it's not constantly being flooded with cortisol and adrenaline the way that we imagine, but there is always a low level of tension. Even when it comes to like neurological activity, like, and the energy that you can put into certain thought processes, you don't have time for that. Your prefrontal lobe is already planning and redirecting and trying to figure out something else. And your fear center is overriding all of its plans anyways. It's harder to function.
Those in survival mode may feel very emotionally numb. there's physical symptoms, there's fatigue, and then there's just this feeling of like, how come I can't organize my thoughts and make sense of my life like other people can? Because you've got so much in your mind. It can also warp our perception of time and really cause it to feel either hyper-accelerated or painfully slow, and that itself contributes to that feeling that we are behind explicitly. For example, there was one study in 2015 by researchers in the UK, and they found that people who have experienced trauma, specifically events that have led us to have a loss of trust
or confidence in the world, people who have experienced this are more likely to encounter a phenomenon known as a sense of foreshortened future. A sense of foreshortened future is essentially the feeling that your future does not exist. If you have gone through trauma or something really hard, you may find that it's really hard, really difficult to like imagine yourself getting married, imagine yourself happy, imagine yourself at 50. Think about what that does to your ability to feel like you are progressing through life. It is incredibly difficult to build towards a future that your brain actually does not acknowledge and does not believe exists because it's just shut that off. You know, other people are able to make five-year plans and they're able to take risks and they
they understand that investing is probably worthwhile because, yeah, of course they're going to be alive at 50 to use that money and they understand the importance of long-term goals. For you, no, survival mode keeps your attention anchored to what is happening right now. So what needs fixing? What could go wrong? What do I need to get through today? The long-term planning is not a priority. It's not a priority until one day, maybe you exit survival mode and you look up and you realize,
oh, wait a second, wait a second. I didn't, I don't think I got the same memo as everybody. else. Like, why didn't I do all these planning things? Like, why do I feel so behind? This is where you need to show yourself some unconditional grace, unconditional compassion, as much of those things as you have available to you, you were living on a shorter psychological timeline. Your brain literally did not imagine the future. You had other priorities. Your nervous system was constantly making you hypervigilant, unable to think about flourishing or fulfillment. And I think you need to give yourself credit for the fact that
that you've accomplished so much just by enduring and surviving that. In my eyes, that's an achievement in itself. I know that's a complicated feeling. I do think it's an achievement. Your emotional and psychological resume is stacked. Even if your professional resume or career resume isn't where you would like it to be, your psychological resume sorted. I also think it's never too late to start over and to start planning and to try again,
but also try again for the first time. but truly, please, if you resonate with this right now, I need you to know, like, I just so desperately want to impress upon you that in my eyes, and I think in many other people's eyes, like, you were not behind. If the start line was here, everybody else was starting from that point, and you just had to, you got dropped at the wrong location. You were all the way back there. You've already run like a whole other race before you have started the race that the majority of people are now enduring. So please have some kindness towards yourself. Okay, I want to talk about the final two reasons you are not as behind as you think and some advice for when you still feel
that way after this short break. The music you love. Your favorite radio stations. Everywhere you go. The podcasts everyone's talking about. All in one place. And it's free. High heart radio. Whatever you want to hear. Listen anytime. Anywhere. Music, radio, podcasts, unlimited audio.
It's on the free IHurt Radio app. Let's go! One app, no subscription. Always free. Grab the free app. I heart radio. Everywhere you go. Always free.
Download the free IHR radio app today. Lisa, we should tell them about our new show. Oh my God, Lexi. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi You Want You. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart.
And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anyone fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes,
good taste is my business, and I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dates, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree. Because you told us how accommodating you are.
Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me.
Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I don't really care. I'm Lacey Mosley. author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts, the True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on incredible guests like Conan O'Brien, Iowa Debrie, Lamorne Morris, and Nicole Beyer. Ooh, I scammed them.
I could talk to you for a hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And the scams run the gamut. I'm talking about scams from the 1800s all the way up to today. I also warn you and keep you safe against scammers. Call your grandparents. Tell your parents to stop clicking on links, please. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. If there's a scam, I'm here to protect you. And I'm also here to laugh with you. So if you like fun, if you like comedy, and you like learning and protecting yourself from criminals, start listening to scam goddess on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal.
I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys? done Terry Gross's Peloton class.
No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry. I'm seeing a reading of Sadako in the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore on 14th. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland bookstore yesterday and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way.
You have to come to the last bookstore though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometime. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone.
I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on artists on the IHeard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle school is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spent real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on
with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this end up. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. And belonging, you could think of belonging as I can be more. myself and I can still be accepted, and then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers, sitting down
with therapist Keir Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts, so you can't do flips, you have on the dressy, up across your legs. That's the range of this run, from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home. We have to get off her device, but the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their life to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy.
Listen to therapy for black girls on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So before the break, we talked about survival mode. In my opinion, I actually think more and more of us are encountering this survival state these days outside of childhood. yes, because of childhood trauma or childhood experiences, but also because life is actually just getting a lot harder. And I do think the bar for surviving is just, I don't think, I feel like I know this, it's just been raised significantly. Like, this wouldn't be, this wouldn't be like
a proper episode about why we feel behind if we didn't acknowledge the fact that the world we have inherited is to put it lightly, a bit of a shit show. It just, it's just, it's just, it's just, just not going great. So much of what we've talked about in this episode, milestone anxiety, the social clock, comparison. It's partly because an older generation dictated what should be possible based on experiences that we can no longer afford and based on a world that no longer exists. And that is the standard we are measuring ourselves too. Housing is really expensive. Grad jobs feel non-existent. Everything close. costs more. So when your soul focus is now, how in the world I'm actually going to afford to live,
bigger dreams and bigger ambitions do get put on hold, and therefore so does a more meaningful version or feeling of progress. There are two psychology terms you should know that describe this really, really well, and describe why this is making you feel behind or fall behind. The first is a well-known one. It's the idea of a scarcity mindset. And the second is less one. known, it's called the cognitive bandwidth tax. They're very much related and they are very much impacting us whilst we encounter this world that feels very difficult to be in. To begin with, let's talk about the scarcity mindset. So put simply, a scarcity mindset occurs when our preoccupation with a lack of resources means that we make irrational decisions. I often talk about
this with regards to dating. You probably heard it in a dating episode, but in this context when you get in a rut or a spiral and you start imagining that you're never going to meet anyone and there's really no good fish left in the sea, this often means that we end up settling for less because we don't have that rort of view of abundance or a sense of possibility when it comes to love. The same applies to all other choices that we make in life. The scarcity mindset is quite universal in that way. If you feel like jobs are scarce, you're not going to take big risks and you're not going to feel like progress is happening. If you feel like money is scarce, you're not going to invest, you're not going to feel like
progress is being made towards your savings. If you feel like it's going to take longer to find a career you love, you're not going to take a gap year, you're not going to take time off, you're not actually going to explore interest, you're not going to feel like there is this progress towards having a fulfilling life. The very real sense of scarcity that we are feeling right now because of the state of the world blocks our ability to be ambitious and build better long-term goals that require sacrifices now, or long-term rewards. We don't make those sacrifices now because we don't believe those sacrifices will pay off considering the state of everything.
And this is why we feel behind our sense of abundance and what feels possible, both now and in the future, feels restricted. And yet we are comparing ourselves to people for whom that context is not the same. Like, they are not experiencing this in the same way. That second concept I mentioned before is also important. and it's similar to the effect of survival mode. The cognitive bandwidth tax is the idea that I spoke about. It was first proposed by these two researchers at Princeton and MIT.
And they basically realized when we have to constantly worry about our basic needs, our attention becomes so narrowly focused on that one thing. It's sometimes called in psychology, attentional tunneling. And we are just so focused on trying to problem solve that, that everything else in our life becomes secondary. and our progress does become quite stagnated. This is particularly relevant for people in their 20s and 30s today. Like, you can't focus on having it all.
You can't work towards having it all because you need to have a job and you need to find a way to make money. And we are continuously comparing ourselves to a previous version of the world where that was less of a concern, like there was more opportunities. this is probably the most important message in this whole episode. Our perception of what it means to be ahead or what it means to be successful has been skewed in so many ways. The reality of how much it takes to get there is a lot greater and harder. As a result, we are facing increasing anxiety to do with, you know, is this going to work or work out? How am I going to find my
path. More of us are feeling behind because what it takes to be ahead is just greater. So when you are drowning under these fears, I want you to remember three critical facts, three critical mindset shifts, three critical things just to remember. Number one, the goal in life is to collect experiences and not to speed through them. There is this level of freedom we experience when we detach from the conceptualization of life as a race and we deeply analyze what is actually important to us and what it actually takes to be happy and what it actually takes for life to be meaningful. All these people who achieve amazing things, like what are they and never really go searching for in the end? Health and love,
which are incidentally the things that they have perhaps compromised in their pursuit of success and in their allegiance to this strict timeline and the strict notion of what makes a person. The other thing they end up chasing is experiences. And they end up chasing all these things that are going to make them feel alive. It's why billionaires keep flying to the moon. They keep spending billions and millions of dollars to never age. They have given away all their time to the pursuit of their dreams and now they are trying to make up for it. And we have the luxury of that time and the luxury of those experiences.
Maybe not flying to the moon. But enjoying ourselves. Like you do not leave this world with accolades or your wealth or your job title. You leave it with experiences and you leave it with the thoughts of the people who loved you. Those are things that you can collect, even if the rest of your life is completely falling apart. Experience and connection are always available, I believe. And I'm not even thinking about good experiences or expensive experiences. Everything is an experience.
Everything contains value. There's also this fascinating research that shows how people who experiment more, who try more things who are more open to the novelty and like the ups and downs of life, especially at a younger age, actually end up being better in the long run than people who just like settled down and chose something very quickly because they're better able to actually articulate what they do and don't like. They have more wisdom. They have more of a sense of preference. I think everything, every experience is teaching you something that the easy path, like just may not have. And one day when it's your time, you're going to look back at all these moments that just
felt like really awful and frustrating and you're going to realize it was teaching you a lesson that you would need one day. Like it's all these awful memories I've had from my early 20s. I like look at them now and I'm like, best lesson. So glad I learned that then. This brings me to my second truth. Number two, no one's journey to success is ever linear ever, ever, ever, ever know. The detours are I tend to believe the path. I was watching this podcast from Angela Duckworth. She's the woman who wrote the book Grit. Great book. And the book situated, which just came out. Actually, I've been reading it. And she was talking about how up until the age of 31, she had literally no idea what she wanted to do with her life. And the very fact that she had no idea,
she claims, is what took her to places that she was meant to be in. That ambiguity, like, the story gets filled with what is meant to be there and with meaningfully. things. Every success story you see, every single one, every single person who says I'm happy with where I am, that is a story of a thousand failures. I don't know where I got that quote. I think it's a quote. I don't think I came up with that idea, but I think it's true. It's also an incredible mindset to have in your 20s. My failures count as much as my successes. If you knew that you were 100 failures away from your biggest win yet and from life working out, like you would get out there and you would start freaking failing. And I actually do believe failure is a bit of a numbers game. So if you're
feeling behind, maybe you're further ahead on that journey. However you want to say it to yourself or picture it, I think that's important. My final reminder, for this whole episode, I know I'm full of wisdom today, but my final reminder, you have so much more time than you think. Every single time, like I interview someone who is 50 or 60, they always say the same thing to me, which is that in your 20s and 30s, you feel like this is the best it will ever be. you feel like life is already over and it's not. You have literally been an adult for less time than you have been a child. Like if you are 25, you've been an adult for seven years, you were a child for 18 years. Give yourself a little bit of grace. Truly, give yourself some credit for what you've been
through, what you've been challenged by, how much you have done, how much you have achieved, how much you have seen, who you've been. I'm sure the list of what you have actually accomplished it's just much longer than you allow yourself to contemplate. You're being too humble. You're being way too humble. And even if you still feel behind and you look at that list and you're like, oh, God, maybe, like actually, that's still not good. Behind who?
Behind what? Every person that you are like comparing yourself to, they have their own insecurities. They have things that they would look at you and they would look at your life and say, wow, yeah, I have this great career and I like have all these things. But like I never actually got to really just like, explore what I wanted. And actually, I never got to really, like, travel and I never got to do those crazy nights with my friends and, like, all I ever did was work. Like, it's, the grass is always greener. That is like one of the best ways to summarize this entire episode. So much of our sense
of inadequacy is perception based. And it's based on who you're comparing yourself to. The fact that you are not acknowledging what you have survived and endured, it's based on on the fact that you're comparing yourself to a life or an other standard or an idea of where you should be that was determined by people like 50, 60 years ago and that world just doesn't exist yet. And it's a perception issue because you are believing that the most valuable experiences that you could have or the most valuable thing you could be is somebody who is successful, who has accolades and who has achievements. And you are not counting your failures and your experiences and the fun that you've had, the same way. You are not valuing that as in
equal measure as the stuff that other people value. And I think if you were to really take those things as important and really saw them as like the currency of a good life, like you would have a lot more kindness to yourself. And I would hope that you would really realize like how much you really have going for you and how much you've achieved. So that, my friends, is the five reasons. I think it's more than five, but let's say six, six. reasons. I don't think you're as behind as you think you are. I hope this episode has been a bit of a solve for your worries and your anxieties that I often share. I feel this very, very deeply as well. It is just a quintessential experience of this time in your life. Take it with a grain of salt.
Please know that. It's a feeling we just kind of have to endure. So I hope that this has helped you endure it a little bit better. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, leave a little white heart emoji below. Let me know that you made it to the end. I hope you enjoyed the episode. And if you haven't yet check out an episode on Netflix, please. It's like one of the easiest ways to help us out. And just to show Netflix, show people that the podcast and video form matters.
Obviously, you don't have to. But it would be, I would very much appreciate it. Thank you as always to our researcher, Lucy Davidson. If you want more content like this, you can follow us on Instagram. You can follow us on Substack. want episode transcripts or shorter version of these episodes delivered directly to your inbox. But until next time, be safe, be kind. Remember that you are not as behind as your little silly brain thinks that you are. We will talk very, very soon.
Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcast. The True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it.
Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. Start listening to Scam Goddess on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Scam Goddess! Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast. where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants.
And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of women's health and gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, Carl thought he was living a normal drama-free life until the messages started. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. Every piece of evidence pointed to the wrong guy.
He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.